[Music]
the kansas city chiefs had a great
offense last year they did not have a
good defense they were 24th in points
per game allowed 31st in yards per game
allowed now they did very well when it
comes to sacks but what did that get
them they couldn't stop teams on third
down they were at 26th in the league and
that defense perceived to be the
achilles heel of the franchise so
they've done enough to make it better
given that guys like eric barry are gone
justin houston is gone d ford was traded
they have added tyron matthew they've
traded for emmanuel log by alex okafor
signed via free agency from the saints
are the chiefs going to be good enough
and have they done enough to make that
that defense as good as it can be yeah
well there's definitely hey it's a
regime train change uh right steve
spagnolos the new defensive coordinator
so certainly he's going to have a little
bit of a different philosophy in general
and i do like that i think the change
was needed on the defensive side of the
ball bob sutton had done a nice job for
years and years but you know the defense
like you said was an issue especially
the last two years now did they do
enough you know yes i like their
improvements i do even though they're
not like huge superstar improvements
alex okafor is a really good edge
outside linebacker defensive end type of
guy who's good against the run and he's
a good pass rusher but not a great pass
sir i sure you know uh again brashad
breeland at corner i think that does
help out the secondary let's not forget
breelan was going to sign a big free
agent contract last year and uh had a
toe or toe issue right that kind of
canceled everything out when when he
went and got his physical and then he
kind of had to sign a one-year prove it
deal and then with the honey badger i
liked that too on the defensive side of
the ball i think the offense was fine
i'm not worried about anything over
there even though i know they lost mitch
morris and all that but the defense i do
think the moves they're making will help
their football team
well and you know i was talking to
somebody last week at the league
meetings about the chiefs and why their
defense was not as good as it needed to
be and you know the offense and the
defense do
work together and
if you're scoring too quickly right
late in the game
you're putting more pressure on your
defense to try to stop the other team
from scoring and we criticize the chiefs
from time to time when it comes to their
ability to manage the clock because they
take too long sometimes you could argue
they score too quickly and that results
in added stress for the defense but it
all you know when you talk about
situational football it's not just what
you do
when you have the ball it's thinking
about what's going to happen when you
don't have the ball that broader sense
of how much time is left what are the
circumstances and how do we thread this
all together so we have more points than
the other team when the game ends yeah
no exactly right it's a team sport and
you do have to marry kind of how you
play your offense and defense together
to
kind of have a cohesive football team
that makes sense now the thing with the
kansas city chiefs is i mean their
defense it wasn't good at anything yet
last year other than sax yes because a
lot of the times patrick mahomes and
andy reid in that offense would get out
to a lead to where yeah d4 justin
houston all they had to worry about was
rushing the passer there was nothing
else to worry about but when the games
were equal or even they couldn't really
stop anything they couldn't cover
anybody in the back end they messed up
things schematically as far as rules and
things like that and then they couldn't
stop the run to go along with it so i
think the one thing we're seeing is
where they might not be as good as
rushing off the edge i think they're
maybe putting a little more uh
eggs in the basket of let's be bigger up
front and more physical and maybe take
away the run game and we'll push the
pocket instead of trying to get d ford
and justin houston around the edge to to
annoy quarterbacks
yeah i mean the bottom line is those 52
sacks what did it all yeah it didn't do
crap exactly right right i mean it's
it's a stack that looks pretty
you got your d4 offsides on the play
that uh
on the play that ultimately could have
clinched the super bowl berth but you
know that that stuff happens and and
ford has owned that but the bottom line
is
we assume that you need to have
a great pass rush if you want to be a
great defense and a great team in
today's nfl and there's such a premium
placed on pass rushers maybe there's an
argument to be made that if you have an
overall great defense
you don't need to be racking up big sack
numbers that you know if you have good
coverage on the back end uh you don't
have to be knocking the quarterback down
to get off the field you can just play
you can play good defense and and result
in more incomplete passes and more
drives ended that way so i think it all
does kind of tie together offense and
defense front end of your defense back
into your defense chris and the chiefs
just need to do a better job of managing
the assets they have so that when the
game is over they do have more points in
the other team that's the bottom line
their offense is good enough to get them
there now their defense has to step up
but their offense also has to be
conscious of the fact that the defense
may need some help by way of game
management helping the offense can maybe
better provide yeah there was some game
certainly this year where the offense
you'd go gosh i wish andy reed and
company would
run the ball a little bit more right man
they're dominating dominating the
offensive line of scrimmage you know run
the ball chew up some time ru you know
rest your defense a little bit but again
it's hard i know that as a pike caller
being andy reid because he goes okay
yeah we got five yards but damn when we
drop back to pass we could go for 60 or
70 yards and that's that's enticing and
awesome and all that but yes i think the
patience of the run game will help out
the overall prospects of the team and to
what you're saying mike too about the
pass rush you know hey pass rushers are
real good i i understand that and you
want to be able to create pressure but
at the same time the buffalo bills the
number two defense in football you know
they were what uh 36 sacks they were
below the middle of the league the
dallas cowboys we talk about their great
front four yeah well they were like in
the middle of the league in sacks too
what they did have was a front four that
could get there and be annoying and then
they always had seven guys in past
passing lanes to make things even extra
annoying for the quarterback to make
decisions
all right we're going to take a break
when we return yesterday we did a draft
of the teams that we think will exceed
the vegas projected win totals for 2019.
today we're going to draft the teams
that we think will come under their
projected win totals we'll do that next
right here on pft live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports